he's an American business executive and
CEO of Apple he serves on the board of
directors of Nike and the National
Football Foundation in 2012 Time
magazine included him in their list of
the 100 most influential people in the
world
he's Tim Cook and here are his top 10
rules for success I spend almost all of
my time on people strategy and execution
and I think that most everything else
Falls from those if you have the most
brilliant people wicked smart people
that collaborate well together if you
set the pin our case we're all about
products so our strategy is very product
oriented if that strategy is right and
if you're executing like crazy there's
there's some things that still arise but
if you get those three right then the
world is a great place Steve was an
original and I don't think there's
another one of those being made and so
I've never really viewed or felt the
weight of trying to be Steve it's just
it's not who I am and it's not my goal
in life you know I am Who I am and
that's that I'm focused on that
and being a great CEO of Apple there's
still things that we very much believe
the the the strive for perfection for
being the best for only doing the best
products for staying focused the fact
that despite this table being so small
that you and I are sitting it you could
put every Apple product on it every
single one that we ship today and yet
this year our revenues will be you know
approximately hundred eighty billion
there's probably no other company on the
face of the earth that could say that I
think you should rarely follow the rules
I think you should write the rules I
think if you do follow things in a
formulaic manner you will wind up at
best being the same as everybody else
maybe you missed something in your
little wars and if you want to excel you
can't do that
I've watched a lot of companies do that
and I think that's the rotten strategy
maybe they'll be good for a few months
or something but and so I think you need
to write your own rules
we're very simple people at Apple we
focus on making the world's best product
and enriching people's lives I think
some companies maybe even the one that
you mentioned maybe they decided that
they could do everything we have to make
sure it Apple that we stay true to focus
laser focus we can only do great things
a few times
only on a few products and it's
incredible everyday to work with what I
considered to be the smartest and most
innovative people on earth and so I
spend my day working with those people
on many different things some things we
didn't talk about that you wanted to
talk about maybe and many things that
that go with running a company of Apple
size and in all the geographies that we
ran in and so forth and I loved every
minute of it it's an incredible place to
be it gives me it is my oxygen so that's
how strongly I feel about it I don't
think that that you're born with a gut I
think you're the gut matures and and
gets better and better over time and
what the struggle that most people have
I think is learning to listen to it and
figuring out how to access it in some
way for it for me though what I found
was that even though I'm an engineer and
an analytical person at heart the most
important decisions I've made had
nothing to do with any of that that
there were always based on intuition and
the Apple one is a prime example of that
you know I remember actually forming my
list of pluses and minuses and I could
not get the chart to work out the way I
wanted it to because I wanted something
to say you know this says I should go to
Apple but it would not there with
nothing financially would do that I
talked to people I trusted that knew me
and they said this is not what you
should do it wasn't so easy and in
people said you know you're just cry
you're working for the top PC company in
the world how could you even think of
doing this you've lost your mind
and yet that voice said go west young
man go west and sometimes you just have
to go for it I think it is misleading to
talk about success without also
referencing failure I know of no one who
has achieved something significant
without also in their own lives
experiencing their share of hardship
frustration and regret so don't believe
that something in your past prevents you
from doing great work in the future to
all of you who doubt yourselves I have
been there too and although today I've
spent time talking about a great
decision I've made some that are far
from it
and like many of you I've had my share
of life's personal challenges and
failures but after many miles on my
journey I've recognized that each of
these difficult periods of life passes
and with each we exit stronger and wiser
the old saying this too shall pass has
certainly proven true for me and I'm
sure it will apply to anyone who
believes it so paint in your mind the
most grand vision where you want to go
in life
prepare trust in and execute on your
intuition and don't get distracted by
life's potholes I learned a lot from
Steve you know it was the it was
absolutely the saddest days of my life
when
he passed away and maybe as much as you
should you should see or predict that I
really didn't and so but at some point
late last year I heard I sort of
somebody kind of shook me and said it's
time to get on and and so that sadness
was replaced by this intense
determination to continue the journey
and and that's where it is today
so what did I learn from him I learned
we could be here all night we probably
all week and maybe a month
I learned that focus is key Apple has a
culture of excellence that is I think so
unique and so special you know I will
I'm not going to witness or permit the
change of it he also taught me that the
joy is in the journey and which is a
revelation for me and and I think he
taught all of us that life is fragile
there was a professor I think his name
is dr. Naylor to Center on Tom Daley yet
time Nadeau and he was a great professor
and one of the things that he asked us
to do was to write a 25-year play maybe
some of you had to do this
and it was more of a you know more of a
personal plan and and the normally I
would never remember this but I was
doing a commencement address few years
ago and I was scrambling for some old
things and I found in a box this plan
and this plan had turned yellow because
of age but I looked at it and I would
say it was it was reasonably accurate
for all of 18 to 24 watts
after it was written and it was nothing
there was nothing a single thing on it
that was accurate post that not a single
thing zero and I think that the lesson
there is at least for me maybe you guys
would be different maybe you have much
more insight into what you may be doing
it for me the journey was not
predictable at all and the it goes sort
of back to the Lincoln quote is the only
thing I believe you can do is prepare
and the world is going to change many
times the environment is going to
changing any times your the companies
you work for are going to ebb and flow
you may wind up in the same company you
may not you may wind up in the same
career you may not you may wind up with
the spouse you're married to now you may
not there are lots of things in your
life I hope that one doesn't change but
there's lots of things that change and I
think that you sort of have to have a
North Star and and stay with the North
Star and let those things go on about
you and sort of find your find your
journey thank you so much for watching I
made this video because Jason Baroni
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what your Tim
Cook's top ten rules had the biggest
impact on you leave it in the comments
and I will join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
you
I work out to keep stress away I'm in
the gym by 5 a.m. every morning if I
have some free time I go to the national
park
I love getting in nature and so this
these are the things that calm my mind
and allow me to think clearly and and so
that's what I did you look for for
people that are not political people
that are not beer beer crowds people
that really don't care who gets credit
people that are can privately celebrate
the achievement but not care if their
name is the one in the lights you know
that there are other there are greater
reasons to do things you look for wicked
smart people you look for people who
appreciate different points of view you
look for people to care enough that they
have an idea at 11:00 at night and they
want to call and talk to you about it
because they're so excited about it they
want to push the idea further and that
they believe that somebody can help them
push the idea another step instead of
them doing everything themselves you
know I've never seen I've never met
anyone at least in my life maybe they
exist that could do something so
incredible by themselves you know in
companies with global footprints and in
in our world in an apples world the the
reason Apple is special is that we focus
on hardware software and services and
the magic happens where those three come
together and so it's unlikely that
somebody that's focused on one of those
in and of themselves can come up with
magic and so you want people
collaborating
in such a way that you can produce these
things that can't be produced otherwise
and you want people to believe in that I
receive hundreds of emails from
customers every day I read them all
often they are written like one might
talk to you at the dining room table at
night last week I received one from a
single mom with a three-year-old
autistic son who was completely
nonverbal the child had recently been
given an iPad and as a result his mother
told me that for the first time in his
life he had found his voice I received
scores of these incredible stories
around the world and I never tire of
reading them we design our products so
they surprise and delight everyone who
uses them and we never never ever
analyze the return on investment we do
it because it is just and right and that
is what respect for human dignity
requires and it is a part of Apple that
I am especially proud of
you